oh hey Mr thing I'm extraordinarily busy
I forgot to staple my essay can I just
use your you broke the rules I didn't
see any rules wrong sir wrong under
Section 37 to be of the syllabus signed
by you it says quite clearly that all
staple usage is no one void if and you
can read it for yourself I the student
forfeit all rights to usage of the
stapler etc etc fax meant to sincennium
Gloria coppam etc etc it's all there
black and white clear as Crystal you
forgot to staple your essay at home so
you get nothing you lose good day sir
I I can just turn it in without Staples
I said good day
I guess I forgot to mention that I
bought some Staples
so shine's a good deed in a weary World
Charlie my name is Greg my boy
[Music]
oh you get to own
oh that seems um cool are you allowed to
do that or not yeah